[Music]
i love this you did something for funny
or die yes you did a short film uh
called jeremy piven's beard yeah yeah
and um and it very funny uh i watched it
today we can't show the whole thing but
let's show a clip anything we need to do
to set it up or just not really it's
just um yeah let's just let's just roll
it see what happens this is a clip funny
or dies jeremy piven's beard
uncle jeremy yeah your beard is really
awkward it's for a part honey ari's
gonna have a beard in the entourage
movie no this is for a new series that
i'm doing mr selfridge we're shooting in
london remember i told you about that
and what's with the glasses some hipster
[ __ ] i'm old okay i need these glasses
to see there's something hipster about
it and can you watch your language
please you'll always be ari
[Music]
you know honey i'm proud of the fact
that i played ari and that the character
will live on but mr selfridge is it
could completely different than ari okay
ari
[Music]
she's very good
she's
she's playing your niece said as an
actress uh
uh her her name is carmen blanchard and
she's a
uh my buddy mark it's it's his daughter
and she's a a great little actress
because you wanted your real niece i
wanted my real niece pearl but pearl's
unavailable she's retired yeah and no
she is wait it's funny pearl famously uh
was in a funny or die video this is your
niece niece pearl with will ferrell
about the landlord that is your niece
wendy's pearl and how old is she now
pearl is eight now and and she's retired
she's retired she says things to me like
no flash photography like literally
i'm like i just want a picture for nana
joyce no flash photography jeremy we we
did i'm making this up man um we did
king lear recently she's in it i swear
to god she's in the youngest shakespeare
company in the world and um she was
still eight she well she was seven when
she performed with me
and we had a great time and you know i
played king lear and she and lily her
sister played my daughters and
afterwards i said you know i'm so proud
of you pearl you did amazingly well i
would love to do this again with you and
she goes yeah and then just kind of
walked away
and while we were rehearsing she turned
to me and i'm just like i'm like listen
i'm living the dream my sister's
directing me i'm with my nieces they now
they know uncle jeremy's an actor and i
can do shakespeare and she turns to me
at one point and she just goes do you
think this is fun for me
and uh i said apparently not apparently
not pearl she's very put upon yes she's
horrified by me now uh this show that
you're doing with selfridge you started
just making it for england and it's
become hugely popular yes you've
it's a big hit in england and uh the
idea then was wow this is doing so well
let's take it to the united states yeah
i mean i i to be honest with you they
invented
the period drama and um you know when we
premiered over there i thought
i don't i didn't know what was going to
happen but
they somehow loved it and we there's
like you know eight and a half million
people a week watch it there and we just
premiered here last week and uh it's
going really well i'm actually heading
back to london to do season two in a
couple of days and and tell people uh
briefly this is based on a real man
harry selfridge it takes place this is
the turn of the century
in 1908 he travels from from chicago
over to london and basically invents the
department store they they weren't
shopping in in the turn of the century
it's very uncouth if you had money you
sent for your dressmaker or you you know
went through catalogs right and he just
kind of transformed the culture and uh
was quite a colorful character um and
he's kind of the antithesis of ari which
has been really fun for me because his
bite is worse than his bark if that
makes any sense i mean he's very
pleasant people-pleasing and then uh
whereas ari from entourage
such a fun part to play yes but his his
bark was worse than his bite yeah you
thought he was a pig but he was
monogamous right harry
is the perfect gentleman but the reality
is at night he's out gambling and and
was seen as somewhat of a womanizer so
and i remember someone said to me you
know you're playing harry selfridge uh
yeah i heard he used to take women into
you know his store and just buy him
anything that you know he wants and i i
just defended harry like he was my
father right and it's hard for me to
separate the guy i love the guy and i
when you when you play a role you just
don't judge them right because that
would be wrong to do
i love conan o'brien the minute i
started playing
yeah it's a disaster yeah it's now it's
awful uh uh
as a young actor when i took on this guy